welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 episode 3 has
potentially just revealed the True
Villain of this show and it's where is
she where is she oh there she is always
sneaks up on us and while maybe this has
been brewing for quite some time on the
surface it isn't until now that Miss
minut has revealed her true intentions
and threatened to Spill the tea on all
of he remains Dark Secrets but as one of
those Secrets did they
this is the sneak peek on new
rockstars where we take the temperature
of whatever we're watching while we head
into the next episode or look ahead in
the next week of fandom and nerdom
joining me on this episode formerly a
clock and now turned a real human being
mod Garrett hi a mod hi there lovely to
be here on the show by the way if you
want to hear us talk about that big
secret Miss minutes teased at the end of
the episode head on over to the break
room Channel because we talked about
that on inside Marvel and we had a lot
of hot takes so on what that secret
could be we sure did now M minutes back
on track let's tick the tuck she's
finally broken a little bit bad here
running out of allies she tries to
persuade ravona with some secret that we
the audience don't yet know about but
what is her end game here I'm wondering
if this was another Agatha all along
moment that it's the witching and
bitching and Ticking ladies who are
running shop around here yes now is she
only just after the body and or love and
endless affections of a Kang or is there
something deeper going on here why is
Miss Menace Gone full villain all of a
sudden or was she always the villain
from the start I think she was always
the villain from the start I just think
you know we got so swept up with the
reveal of he who remains in the final
episode of Loki season 1 the elevator
doors opened he took over the show
rightfully rightfully but I think we
forgot the craziest thing to happen in
that seon one finale was that jump scare
it retroactively recharacterized every
moment we saw Mis minutes and how creepy
she was yes and in season two they've
just escalated that kind of like the the
monster in a a well structured horror
film they leave the the entity in the
shadows and then miss Min just kind of
talked about for the first couple of
episodes then episode three right away
she says bless your heart we all know
what that means I like that she's being
quite unassuming this entire time but I
think also now is the best time ever to
talk about the fact that AI is taken
over isn't it and AI is the real threat
we are years away from Skynet being a
reality so the fact that Miss minutes is
starting to kind of like you know yeah
get the the clock cogs spinning it makes
a lot of sense um and I actually really
like the dichotomy between these two
villains maybe it's like two sides of
the same clock uh where you've got Kang
who we've seen as erratic uh we've seen
him as and even like um timely he's also
quite unstable but then you've got this
very very certain you know she's by the
minutes here she's very in control she's
very calm and I really think that
there's something going on with um that
balance between those two and I think
that you know just because K's supposed
to be the Conqueror doesn't mean the AI
who knows every thing isn't actually
behind this as well oh absolutely this
is
um I love everything about this season
I'm just going to say that from it's so
good it's so good I know we got a little
bit of heat because we found the start
of episode two a little confusing
because it just threw us straight back
into it but that's not to say that these
episodes haven't been bringing it they
they have been bringing it it's been the
best Loki as a whole season one and now
season two now we'll see if they stick
The Landing but so far it has been the
best thing Marvel has produced since
Avengers endgame without a doubt I I
mean I was a big fan of One Division as
well they're both very very different
but I love that we are looking at sort
of like I mean it's weird here because
Loki we kind of keep forgetting that he
is a God and he's sometimes a secondary
character in some of these moments
because we are talking like it's bigger
than him um whereas One Division I
really liked the look of grief and it
was a lot more personalized sort of like
look at these characters do go back and
on W Vision they are both great they are
both great it's just W Vision didn't
stick The Landing quite as much as we
wanted and even Jack schaer has said
like yeah they kept giving us like uh
they said we'll figure out the ending
later and you can kind of see that but
overall you're right W vision is up
there well they're getting show Runners
now so I think we're going to have a lot
more structure instead of like you know
effort we'll do it live kind of
mentality so but you know it whatever
they've been doing and I think it just
happened to work out in the case for
Loki with season one you had Mike
Waldren in Kate Haron just understood
what the vision of this show was and
then Kevin Wright was just kind of their
champion from the executive side and so
Kevin Wright I think fully gets the show
and then you have uh Benson and Morehead
this season that are just carrying that
Vision forward I think my only worry was
the direction because they're doing
different directors for many of the
episodes but uh and most of the time I'm
like make sure you hire DGA directors to
direct because it's hard to do um they
have Dan delu did episode two and KRA
farani did episode three kaser far honey
did all the production design of season
one of Loki and now season two and is
just so talented and such a Visionary
but getting to the question of like Miss
minuts Ren Slayer he who remains the
love triangle between these three is so
interesting to me who had that on their
bingo card not me not me at all like you
know it just seemed like I didn't think
the show would go there like you think
like oh there's like this AI sentient
thing that was an invention of this
weird creepy Creator this uh this kind
of pigmon esque story uh but you don't
think they're going to go there but she
gets so horny in this episode and and
it's like I was questioning why would
you want a physical body if you can
appear anywhere in any time I just think
she misses you must the only way you
would want a physical body is if at one
point in your existence you had one and
you miss it so I think he might have
exted her could agree with that argument
if you are constantly seeing I mean
Grass Is Always Greener you cover what
you don't have and so I don't know if
she's necessarily ever had it and I
think that that's why she's feeling
inferior because it's like yes she's
been trusted yes she knows everything uh
she could have easily had her um data
wiped at any time but it sounds like
there's you know a lot of trust there
because she's only Ai and I think that
maybe it's an empty promise uh one day
my Prince Will Come one day I'll get my
body um but I think by limiting her in
that capacity this entire time it almost
puts her in her place where she's not as
much of a threat so should she get her
own body that's the point of no return
that's when she becomes completely
Unstoppable because would she then be
able to change her appearance at any at
any given time um you know and that
that's just a whole other superpower
that will render her even more powerful
I think I think we could compare her to
Ultron in the MCU cuz Ultron I think
found a lot of power in being detached
from any one body but he did have one
vibranium shell that he made that was
kind of like the Ultron Prime in that
final battle uh but I think he still
recognized that like his power was how
he he was kind of like portable and like
I wonder if like would Ai and its in
would Skynet and its Infinite Wisdom uh
view the human biological need to
procreate and to bang as a limitation
like would they just be like oh cuz if
you think about it like the human's
instinctive need to want to have sex is
kind of like you could argue from an AI
perspective a limitation on our
technological possibilities yeah if if
you remove that from the equation you
know you take have a very fast path
towards unlimited power which is
obviously their goal but the question
would be what are you doing it for I
guess if we're going to talk about like
ethics IM morality and worthwhileness of
procreation I don't want get into that
here actually I want to go back to the
Ultron comparison cuz what I think is
interesting with M min's weakness is
that she I believe if if it's Ai and she
doesn't have a body she can be switched
off it's it's through the temp pad uh
and it's through um you know however she
can project herself but if she is only a
I'm without a body you can destroy it
still whether it's a virus I don't know
that if we're in a universe where
viruses exist because it's the TVA and
time doesn't even exist um but you know
there's an option where you can which is
again why she's not been given a body um
but a big thing that I noticed about M
minutes that we have not seen before I
mean yes she's thirsty um she wants to
tick his talk but also she's vulnerable
she is having a moment where she's
showing vulnerability because she's not
in complete control I think that she
thought she had something with Kang that
was unbreakable unbendable and um she's
seen the cracks in the plan here so
she's now bringing in someone else who
she was in competition with but now is
seeing as an ally to bring her in so
that she's got um another way to see out
her plan and I think that that's of
really interesting because Kang was
always at the top and then ravona and um
Miz mes were tangentially sort of like
the side Companions and so if they team
up he's rendered redundant he's rendered
useless so I think we can have a full
Dynamic change here that's why I think
we are seeing like a Taylor Swift Sophie
Turner team up here uh and I think it's
wonder I love that you know
that I think it's delightful that
they're comparing notes and I um but to
the question of did they I do not think
on Disney Plus on Bob iger's Disney plus
will they allow uh the idea that that he
remains made a living that that he could
do that too but I do think that her
programming may have either been based
on or even extracted from someone that
he did sleep with oh interesting where
is right now got it resid
do you know that that's a remaining
thing we look at these character traits
like who are these people at a
fundamental level Kang and I believe
every iteration of him will not team up
will always remain Lone Wolf is always
the Apex he is at the top of the chain
um and so any single time someone wants
a partnership that's like the word that
cannot be uttered and that's makes
everything crumble and I think for M
minutes it's wanting to be needed so
those two that is not a compatible you
can't ever be a partnership when one
wants companionship and the other one
doesn't so yeah yeah and I think that
every iteration of Kang we're going to
come to that same conclusion that's kind
of their their um fatal flaw or their
their whatever the you know in Greek
tragedies there's always just the one
thing that brings you down and I think
it's that I think it's it's inability to
work in a partnership and or share the
credit mind you raon has been a little
bit like that she's been lying she's
deceitful she's been at the top of um
the chain there and she's made sure that
everyone under her works for her as well
so there's a bit of a sort of like a
Kang similarity of being on the top of
the food chain and not necessarily being
completely trustful or trusting at the
same time that's a good point what Kang
seems to have with Miss minutes and with
Ren Slayer Ren Slayer seems to have with
Mobius a little bit Yeah you could say
you're passing it down the chain of
command yeah like they'd kind of have
their own little break up they have a
little bit of whiskey at the end of the
day even though do they have a start and
end of a workday this is what keeps me
up at night do they go to the bathroom
where do they sleep Eric where's the
breakdown on their
bed do I think
theying is there a gym are there any
amenities do they have tandem parking
spots or is it
streetking they do get get I love the
theories going around that the pie is
what's wiping brains and Minds as well
there there's yeah in August we had a
whole thing I I speculated last summer
that it was soilent green that they that
they that they recycle employees uh
deceased remains and turn it into the
food it's just we'll see variant plus my
favorite excuse me there's an eyeball in
my key line pie I didn't say remove it I
just want to let you know
complim now long time new rockstars
viewers know how much we use geology and
how long we've been using it for but if
this is your first time hearing about
geology get ready for Blockbuster
quality skincare on a student film
budget geology is a 23 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30second quiz right now if you use
the code new rockstars 100 geology will
give you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a wild
offer one of the best they've ever given
our audience so click the link in the
description or go to G log. i/ rockstars
100 to get started before we continue
with our discussion we got a big week
coming up on new rock stars and the
breakroom and the Deep dive so on uh
we're going to continue talking about
Loki obviously our Loki episode 4
breakdown will be on the new Rockstar
Channel Thursday night but before that
you're going to see Tommy and mod and me
reacting to the episode and what happens
in episode four also we got a special
October treat a breakdown of the 1996
West Craven
scream I am so excited for you guys to
see this it's one of my favorite videos
we've done in a long time it uh goes
into why scream despite it being like
knowingly derivative of horror movies
that came out in the previous decade is
really one of the most important horror
films in our lifetimes yes it's like a
bit of a '90s kid Nostalgia thing but it
is so important not only did it launch a
franchise it like cified what who dunit
could be in the Modern Age It's just so
good and then we're going to continue
with our coverage of gen V in Rick and
Morty and then on the Deep dive either
this week or early next week you will
see our analysis of uh John Carpenter's
The Thing
1982 another amazing D it story body
horror Rob Bin's prop work and how Stan
Winston came in to help out and it's
again I think the greatest who done it
in cinema history to where people are
still looking at Clues and finding new
things in it um I confessions I don't
watch horror
movies you're missing out mod am I or am
I sleeping really well at night maybe
I'll say this I'll say this some horror
movies are like I think Ari Aster's
horror movies are really just designed
to make you uncomfortable um and some
horror movies don't do that I think some
horror movies just like give you a
fascinating outlook on human nature and
uh and excite you um but I agree some
horror movies are kind of I'm the kind
of person I would love I love reading
about horror movies not watching them so
I would rather see your breakdown and
deep dive on scream and the thing than
actually watch those movies so thank you
for making people like me the kind of
content that I can we got you covered
mod thank you also be sure to check out
nerd rot. shop where you can always grab
the latest and greatest new rock stars
gear I'm wearing one of my favorite
shirts they've ever released this is
like a mobious ke pie speaking of the
eyeball pie um this shirt's awesome but
we also have a new shirt that's going to
be OB themed you guys are going to love
this shirt so keep an eye out for that
we stand OB here now you got this um
this bit in your video yesterday let's
talk about the differences between
Victor timley for a moment there's
different ones um he's obviously very
very different to Kang as well but at
the beginning of the episode we are
introduced to a Victor from the sacred
timeline he's the one that ravona gives
the book to when he's a child slip it
through the window but then the rest of
the episode we with an adult Branch time
timeline timely so this isn't sacred
timeline Victor this is a branch so this
is like a very different version can we
just break this down a little bit so is
the timely from the sacred timeline the
one who becomes he who remains yes um or
at least a new cycle of he who remains
at least I think that's what this
episode is saying okay I had to rewatch
this episode a few times too mod um we
have a video yesterday that you could
check out where I I think I have a
pretty good explanation but the the idea
is that if you rewatch The season 1
finale uh he remain story says that eons
ago in the 31st Century a variant of me
so one of my variants I don't think he
was saying he was from the 31st Century
you know at the time we thought that
like all kangs originated as Nathaniel
Richards in the 31st century and he just
kind of credited another variant to be
like milliseconds before the rest to
discover multiversal techn technology
okay um I think the idea is that most
kangs originated as a guy named
Nathaniel Richards a descendant of Reed
Richards who lives in the 31st Century
they discover multiversal travel at the
same time think of like Rick versus Rick
Prime in the Rick and Morty show they
all kind of Discover it at the same time
and then they share resources but then
they go to war um but he remain says
that he was kind of like the top of that
dog pile because he was able to tame
elath and then and then prune all the
other timelines I think the idea is that
the Kang that becomes he remains was
named Victor timley and existed on the
sacred timeline in the 1860s what's
confusing though is he just so happens
to look exactly like Jonathan major I
think the only way this makes sense at
least in my head is that one of the
Waring kings in the 31st Century as part
of their plan kidnapped baby version of
kangs from like the 30th Century or
whatever something like that and hid
them in the sacred timeline or hid at
least one of them in the sacred timeline
as a kind of failsafe contingency plan a
Sleeper Cell that they could activate by
giving them the right book at the right
time that I mean I think either way the
idea was he's trying to complete the
loop by finding his origin point in
1860s Chicago give his younger self the
book and then complete the cycle so that
young man will go on to invent the TVA
right that that actually is more of an
oror thing as well though because if
he's yeah it's like where does it ever
begin because his 31st century is
bringing him back to the 19th centur
okay that's H okay it is confusing and I
could be totally wrong it just based on
this episode that's the only way that
makes sense if they say that this young
man who's going to grow up to look
exactly like Victor exactly like
Jonathan major is on the sacred timeline
it'd be one thing if he was in a branch
but the fact that he's in the sacred
timeline that just says that he was
there in the MCU history we've been
watching since the beginning and so for
him to grow up to look like Jonathan
major he must have a DNA connection to
that 31st Century war that he remains
talked about okay I was going to say
because we saw a branch Victor timley
who does look like Jonathan Mages as
well but that's a branch version but he
also had that same kind of like temporal
Loom yeah I think what made it a branch
is that he was given the book I think
the book made it split off and that
became a Nexus event that uh created a
branch but the reason why he doesn't get
pruned is that basically he remains so
like he remains is in control of all of
it so he can say what is defined as
sacred timeline and what is Branch
timeline and which branches just kind of
get erased from the archives and allow
to exist um okay now earlier I was
saying that I my theory is that all
kangs will be adverse to partnership
he's going to be on the throne the whole
time he's in command he's the Conqueror
but in episode one we here he who
remains tell Rona I will be proud to
lead with you lead with you thank you
for being on my team in this episode
timley cast her away at the M mention of
a partnership so that is an absolute 180
why is that happening is it because this
is the branch version of him and his
eyes been on the prize um and this we're
going to meet a later Kang who then
recognizes partnership is important what
help me help me come to terms with what
that's about yeah I think that really is
the question of this show like why can't
he have a partnership um I think I think
the idea was like the the audio
recording that we heard in episode one
of this season was like covered up I
don't think like people were supposed to
hear it I think he he makes that promise
to her but I think this is evidence like
this is the secret that I think Miss
minut is going to tell RN Slayer is that
he made promises to Ren Slayer but it
was all I think he used her to
win the war and then right when it came
time to share the right to rule the TVA
he backed out out and he said oh I can't
trust you and then and then because I
think that's just kind of his fatal flaw
he's afraid of being stabbed in the back
isn't it interesting that Loki was
always the master manipulator but now
we've got Kang who's like taken front
seat for being a manipul manipulator
like that we don't like liars we don't
like people who back out of their
promises not cool not cool you know
what's interesting is the fact that Loki
was I don't know if Marvel planned this
or it was just kind of a happy accident
that they decided to do this in Avengers
endgame but the fact that Loki was
branched from the events like right
after being defeated by The Avengers in
the 2012 battle that was the moment this
Loki that was his like origin point like
I think that's telling if you were to
prune Loki from a different point in his
history like during the events of the
2011 Thor movie when he was trying to
conquer Asgard or like when he was like
being choked by Thanos or something like
that you probably would have had a
completely different story in this Loki
series I think that Loki um has leared
about partnership and teamwork and
something bigger than himself CU his eye
was his eye was always on the prize he
was always selfish in his Endeavor but
he had a very clear goal which I
actually admire and that was to rule
midgard like this guy just wanted power
over Earth but when you go into a place
like the TVA and there's a drawer with
Infinity Stones in it that are just
trinkets his goals what was important to
him has been so minimized because now
he's discovered that there's so much
that is just bigger than him and I think
that that was a very humbling moment for
him through season one and now it's like
you know he has these Mo moments with
Sylvie where it's like hey stop stop
making this about us like he's almost
talking to a a past version of himself
that was selfish and he's like this is
bigger than us like I I I kind of like
the evolution that we've had of Loki but
you're right like that Pinnacle moment
was there was room to change because he
failed again but that's what lokis do
we're kind of doing a heat check right
now so let's just go into our heat check
segment this is when we give our
thoughts on how the season is going are
are we feeling positive are we worried
for upcoming episodes I will say this
episode kind of felt like a second pilot
or at least the second first episode in
the way that it introduce some new
characters and New Concepts how are you
feeling mod as we go into episode four
confident um I like that you know we are
in the same vein of season one where
it's like you can pick a part on the
timeline and you can go in there and
you've got a you know a whole new um
scope of surroundings we've been in the
future we've been in the past been on
different planets before so it's really
cool to see this point in time that
they're exploring um but now because
we've had a whole season to establish
the TVA and they're supposed to bring it
down um we're learning more about who
Rona really is we're learning more about
Mobius like why is he so against
learning who uh who his past life was um
why is he blindly following TVA now um I
I I just I love this show and I think
that it's just going to get better and
better and hopefully um do are we
getting a season 3 we better I think
Marvel just needs to continue building
out this mythology it's the best once
you have something this good um like I
don't I don't I I do not need six
seasons of it no but if you want to do
like a third season that's Eight
Episodes to round it out I wouldn't say
no to that and then take a couple years
to work on it like I need it next year
but like
2025 do you reckon they can keep Owen
Wilson and Tom Heston for that long
that'd be tough but if you're look
Tom Heston Owen Wilson they're big names
they're only going to get bigger names
as a result of shows like this but it
seems like they have a lot of fun on
this yeah uh I think it's gonna be
harder to keep people like KIU Kuan
honestly because his his star power is
just blowing up true true all right no
I'm feeling good heat check hot hot hot
yeah this might be them like other than
this between episode one and episode two
or between no episodes in episode one I
think this might be the most excited
this episode three it's just I don't
know it feels like the fact that you
know my wife's family comes from the
south side of Chicago I weirdly know a
lot about Chicago History I love this
point in history with the the current
Wars between um Tesla and Edison and
this was like the turn of the century
the Chicago World's Fair is a setting
the backdrop of HH Holmes um monstrous
killings in his Murder Castle uh like so
much of this episode was just like this
is I'm eating good right now you know
this is meanwhile as an Aussie uh who
really had very little interest in how
uh electricity came about uh I knew
diddly dick Squad about this episode so
I've learned more from hearing you
explain it than I did watching the
episode it's just like hey I want to
hold on to this feeling for for the dark
times because you know we're going to
have some dark times ahead who knows how
the Marvels is going to go who knows
what's going to happen if like Deadpool
has to get delayed don't you dare you
take that back son I know I'm knocking
on all the wood that it won't
but God I'm just going to remember this
feeling and remember talk about this
episode with you mod and and ride this
high for as long as I can you're doing
good Loki keep it up keep it up and
that's where we'll leave it for this
episode of this sneak
peek follow new rockstars on Twitter
please follow mod on all social media
atod Garrett you can follow me at eaos
and we'll see you next week thanks for
watching y'all
bye
yeah